we are learning more about the two
children killed in a suspected DUI crash
in North Las Vegas Sunday evening good
afternoon thank you for joining us at 4
I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Christian
Casitas we're also learning more about
what police believe contributed to that
violent crash as neighbors tell us that
they've asked for help in that specific
area before right Matthew joins us live
on Scott Robinson near Lone Mountain in
Clayton where our neighbors say they're
very familiar with these traffic issues
yeah Kirsten Christian they're very
aware of that but before we get into
that let's start with the coroner's
office they have identified those two
victims three-year-old Taylor Wilmer
two-year-old Rose Wilmer you can see the
memorial from this crash right behind me
here people have been coming out since
yesterday for it this is all along a
road that's the access point to several
neighborhoods you can see homes lying
the street but the people living in them
they say Sunday's crash joins a growing
list of incidents here with seemingly no
solution in sight
a sight Davis Mallory says he's seen
before my wife she was in the bedroom
right there at that time so if they
would have went through that wall he was
going to go right into the bedroom where
she was at this palm tree is what he
says prevented four to five cars from
slamming into his backyard they go down
that street like super fast the
sprinklers come on at night time so when
the sprinklers come on they the water
drips down on that side of the road like
right by my back wall right there where
that tree is at and they slide every
single time right into that tree
a blind spot on Scott Robinson Boulevard
with no speed bumps or stop signs where
a single vehicle took the lives of two
little girls just heard it loud it
sounded like a gunshot ping Andrew
Maldonado who lives on one of the
corners says a car rammed into his
family's backyard years ago the drivers
allegedly emerging with alcohol bottles
in their hands definitely gave us
anxiety and just let alone even being in
our backyard oh when's the next person
going to come through and smash their
backyard North Las Vegas Police
confirmed Sunday's crash was the fourth
vehicle collision here this year and was
even higher over the past two years also
this year the department received a
hundred thousand State dollars to
address impaired driving and 176 000 to
reduce vehicle fatalities but neighbors
still fearing the next crash could be in
their backyard this backyard they traded
like a NASCAR rally you know it's like
it's like there's no speed limit here
now neighbors say they've asked for
speed control measures here for years as
City representative tells me that speed
bumps are not an option that's because
of how the roads designated and how it
impedes emergency service access but
they do add those enforcement efforts
with all those new Grant dollars could
potentially be used and focused on this
specific Street for now reporting live
near Loden mountain and Clayton rymathy
8 News Now